the b580 was the first GPU launch in
years that people were genuinely excited
about and Intel is hoping to keep that
hype train chugging along with the new
cheaper Intel Arc
b570 it's a slightly cut down version of
the b580 and today we're looking at the
ASRock Challenger OC
version and oh well uh it's a GPU who
would have expected in the Box we also
got quick installation guides and a
warranty notice and that's about it it's
a nice reasonably sized car which I'm
happy to see because some of the aib
designs for the b580 were like
needlessly large like I it did not need
a triple fan design at a 190 WT card
this is nice and relatively small though
it is a little tall so if you have a
pretty narrow case you might come into
compatibility issues but I I would
expect this to fit pretty much anywhere
you'd want to put it just looking around
the card we can see that it has a single
8 Pin VGA power connector because this
is a card that doesn't require a lot of
juice just 150 wats they do recommend a
600 W power supply which honestly
depending on your CPU is probably going
to be over kill but in our 580 review we
did notice that there are chances of
large transient spikes on these Intel
cards so your mileage may vary I take
the recommendation that's on the box and
it's got three display port 21s and one
HDMI
2.1a the slot is a 16x connection though
it is just a 8X card you got a piece of
a slot cover I don't know this there
what is there to say about a graphics
card I think this one's ugly I wouldn't
buy this uh for its looks ASRock
advertises that it has a stylish back
plate but it's stylish if you like Tonka
trucks and or rocket ships I do like
that it maintains the flow through
cooler design the board itself looks a
little bit longer than the reference
ones from Intel on the b580 but um I
don't really think that that's an issue
I also think that the nice big fans are
going to be great for quiet operation
even if it is a little Ugo because they
maintained this nice flowthrough cooler
you can kind of see through here like
look at how much space you have behind
on the back plate it's just kind of
needless but that's just what's on the
outside it's what's on the inside that
counts and inside this is the b570 so
let's talk a little bit about what that
means as I said earlier the b570 is a
slightly cut down version of the b580
this is 10 GB of gddr6 memory versus the
12 GB found on the b580 and it's still
based on Intel xe2 architecture the new
xe2 architecture comes with basically
improvements to every single possible
part it is quite the change over the
original XC architecture that's found on
The Alchemist series of gpus and it has
caused a massive uplift in performance
and huge improvements in efficiency but
does that 10% cut result in a 10% hit to
Performance well I'll tell you all about
it we'll have graphs from the labs but
you do have to wait through this sponsor
section thanks to Jawa for sponsoring
today's video sell your old graphics
card and offset the cost of a new one
with the help of Jaa an online
Marketplace for gamers and PC
enthusiasts all you have to do is follow
the steps on their site to get an
instant quote and a free shipping label
that's right no more going through the
hassle of listing them for sale yourself
and having to actually talk to real life
people ew they'll also have some PCS
with the new b570 put together by their
verified Builder soon so stay tuned for
those if you're looking for something
ready to go click the link in the
description to learn more today one
thing I noticed right away is that that
rgb's really bright um needlessly so
what's a little bit more enjoyable is
the fact that the fans have a zero decel
mode where they just don't run when uh
things are nice and cool uh you
appreciate it you love to not hear it as
I was saying the b570 is a cut down
version of the b580 by about 10% but
it's usually not a onetoone thing the
470 TI and the 470 super are the same
chip but their performance and their
Cuda cor counts do not correlate one to
one the difference in Cuda cor is
greater than the difference in
performance between those two cards
that's pretty normal usually the Gap is
a little bit smaller so I'm hoping to
see that this card performs closer to
the maybe just 8% worse than the b580
that's kind of optimistic so the b580
already a great price 250 bucks for a
really highly performed card b570 is
coming in $30 cheaper except for this
one specifically because it's an OC
variant uh it's $10 more but that $10
brings a 100 MHz OC from the factory
which brings it pretty close to how fast
the b580 runs the b580 runs at 2670 MHz
and the ASRock Challenger b570 is
running at 2600 MHz so maybe that will
make up some of the performance even
more let's take a look at Labs numbers
across all of our games in 1080 we see
the Intel Arc b580 outperforming the
b570 by about 15 1 12% for the average
FPS and 16%
for low FPS and that's kind of
disappointing considering that this is
just a prey Jack away from
$250 you could literally skip lunch
twice and like buy a better GPU it's
almost too close in price for it to make
a ton of sense it doesn't appear to have
any major problems in any specific games
across our suite it's a consistent loss
yeah Alex 2 there's nothing interesting
Blackmouth Wukong none of these cards
can really handle it with not even the
4060 being able to pass 30 frames per
second to be fair Blackmouth Wukong is
at cinematic settings uh which kind of
brings every system to its knees but the
4060 is only winning by 7 to 12% and
that card is still
$300 the question might be do you want
the 580 right now and can't get it
because it's pretty hard to get well
maybe you can deal with the 570 but even
then it's just that's a pretty big
disappointment in terms of performance
relative to the b580 is price and it
1080p rate tracing it doesn't really get
any better the 4060 and the b580 both
lead the b570 by about 16% in average
frame rates and in 1% lows the 4060 wins
by 20% it's kind of a blowout and the
b580 is at 19% better when you're not
saving that much money it becomes hard
to justify that much of a performance
hit when we look at 1440p the story gets
a little bit better for the b570 just as
we saw with Alchemist gpus and with the
b580 Intel really scales well when the
resolution is cranked the b570 basically
catches right up with the RTX 460 the
RTX 460 is only leading by about 2% in
averages and
4.7% in lows that's a really compelling
offer right like this is $70 cheaper
than the 4060 but it's just not as clear
of a victory as the b580 was which was
basically just an obvious win do you
know what is kind of crazy for how hard
Nvidia pushes cyberp Punk it doesn't win
it any resolution against the Intel
cards I guess this is as good of a time
as I to talk about an elephant that has
been in the room Hardware unboxed found
that on Lower tier CPUs Intel could fall
really far behind compared to the RTX
4060 but when you pair it with a
high-end CPU like how what reviewers
typically use to test gpus to make sure
that there's no bottlenecks it starts to
look a lot better it scales massively
which I know that you might be getting
cynical there is probably you probably
want to go oh they just made sure it was
optimized for whatever the reviewers
used so the reviewers would praise it
and give it good press and I'm not
saying that they didn't do that but what
I am saying is that it's more likely
tied to significant driver overhead
which means that if you are bottlenecked
at the CPU the bottleneck is going to be
way tighter on an Intel card than on an
Nvidia card uh there are some real deep
Dives that have been done chips and
cheese did a really interesting blog
post where he broke down API calls as
well as like everything that's going
into a specific frame while it's
rendering on the arc that shows that
there is a lot of efficiency gains that
Intel still needs to make that it's
going to reduce the load on your CPU but
it's important to note that the whole
reason that we test with high-end CPUs
is to show the hardware working without
a bottleneck so you know your mileage
may vary it would be fair to expect that
Intel's going to probably overcome these
issues obviously you should never buy a
product based on future promises that it
will improve you should only purchase
something based on how it is at the
moment you get it so make sure to take a
look at those other articles and videos
before you make a purchasing decision
also you should take a look at the live
stream that we're doing where we're
going to be testing out any game that
viewers are asking for on the new b570
to see how they run to see if those
driver issues are getting worked done we
will say it's better than it was a few
years back with our Alchemist but
clearly there's still some work to be
done on top of that you also have
features like
xs2 um which comes with a whole host of
features they have like a an Nvidia
reflex clone a frame gen clone as well
as a super sampling clone xss is like
super resolution and stuff is quite good
um and their frame gen's prob arguably
better than amds but it's a very quiet
card uh and if that's a priority for you
I think you'd be pretty happy um if we
take a look at Hardware info how are we
doing for temperatures staying at 60 I
wonder if we can get it a little bit
higher and see how loud this thing will
get under an intense load it's h about
70° on the
GPU uh the core temperatur is at 56
memory temperatures at 70 the GPU Global
temperature is usually the one you want
to look at the GPU Global setting is
just the hottest sensor that is on this
card it's it's very quiet for staying at
70° C also it should be noted it's on a
test bench this is like a best case
scenario thermally and we're not running
it for a super long time if it was in a
case it would saturate the air and you'd
see temperatures climb the max
temperature for these gpus is I believe
85° C so you're not it doesn't seem like
we're too close though it might actually
be lower on this card cuz it looks like
we are downclocking now that we are at
72° we're actually hitting above what
the OC says it's reporting 2750 MHz and
2650 MHz and it's supposed to be OC to
just 2600 MHz yeah it's still dead quiet
uh if you wanted you could easily make a
tradeoff for a little bit more noise if
you wanted it to run even cooler now
we're settling in at 2600 so maybe it's
going to at the start of a heavy
workload it's going to overshoot that OC
but now it's kind of settling in so on
top of getting xcss 2 you also have
other great features like a super
capable uh encoder and decoder on the
card uh quicksync is awesome so if
you're somebody who's into streaming and
you want to do av1 encoding or even just
typical h264 stuff you're going to have
a super high performance card that's
going to be able to handle a lot of
streams or a like a really high
resolution video this has the same
encoder and decoder it's not cut down in
any way compared to what's on the b580
so you can check out a review on that
honestly I think that it's just not
really enough to justify how small of a
price cut it is the fact that it doesn't
keep up with the 4060 is a
bummer even though price to Performance
it probably still puts up a good fight I
just really think that if you can find a
b580 at MSRP you're just going to be
better off with that so like why does
this exist if this was at2 200 $ it
would be super compelling though it
would risk Intel kind of probably
cannibalizing their own sales so I can
see why they kind of had to you know
make a decision but if all of the aib OC
cards are going to be just $20 cheaper
than a referenced b580 or even just $30
cheaper than like an aib b580 why does
this exist the answer is probably yields
Intel uh will have b580 chips that just
aren't going to be functioning properly
turn turn off a few of those cores slap
a new name on it and you can sell that
if it is for yields and they're trying
to sell through stuff they should make a
more compelling price offer but as we've
seen there's already availability
problems with the b580 so maybe that'll
soften that but I don't know thank you
for watching short circuit if you like
this video uh check out the live stream
uh where we try out a ton of different
games we'll probably play Marvel rivals
on that live stream or take a look at
another GPU that we've covered on this
channel